forget brexit forget Trump we have a new
fault line dividing the Western world
depending on your point of view Serena
Williams's tirade against an umpire at
the US Open was bang out of line or a
rallying call for women and sport to be
treated the same as men
last Saturday she exploded into a
massive McEnroe star tanti against
Carlos Ramos after he docked her a point
for receiving coaching then another for
breaking her racquet she furiously
denied she had been coached called him a
liar and a thief then he took a whole
game off her I have a daughter and stand
up for what's right for her she shouted
suggesting he was penalizing her not
because of code violations that men get
away with all the time but because she
was a woman her behavior has divided
tennis as has a controversial Australian
cartoon depicting Williams having a
tantrum which many have called out as
racist yes she lost her cool and was
rightly punished for that but why
shouldn't she be angry and should she
really be penalized for continuing this
battle of the sexes I'm all in favor of
women doing great things and achieving
and I really respect you know Serena's
Talon what she's achieved etc but I I do
get slightly dismayed when things drawn
in to this happens because I'm a woman
and this happens because I'm a man
because actually you know what what
Serena was picked what what I want as a
woman is to be treated equally and what
I mean by that is if I smash a racquet
up in a game that you're not allowed to
smash a racquet off I deserve to be
penalized if I start shouting and
bawling and not relenting an umpire I
deserve to be penalized if I take or if
coaching has happened in a game where
coaching is not allowed to have button I
deserve to be penalized and actually
when people are talking about this as a
sexist thing when you look at the
violations that have been issued for men
and women we are about to actually yeah
so actually we've
some stats on this then so it is way
more men so 26 men were fined and only
ten women were fined for violations so I
don't believe actually that women are
being treated unfair unfairly because of
their saying man I just think it's it's
nice to have the debate but I think at
some point in it we need to stop trying
to make everything about men at vs. we
need to spin through a few examples of
where men have been equally outspoken
maybe rude and they haven't been even
docked a point just merely given a code
violation so it's sit tight in 2016
French Open Nick care EOS given a code
violation for shouting at a ball boy and
then accused the umpire of incredible
bias no further action at the Rio
Olympics Andy Murray had a code
violation for calling Carlos from a
stupid and therefore other action in
2017 Novak Djokovic shouted you're
losing your mind for being docked at
first serve for a time violation Rafael
Nadal Chris eyes Ramos for treating him
like a machine after being given a
warning for slow pay no further action
in this year's Australian Open Nick
chaos shouted at the umpire for giving
him a foot fault but wasn't given a
further penalty then at Wimbledon jaakko
accused Carlos Ramos of double standards
for a code violation after smashing his
racquet he shouted was given multiple
verbal warnings still no point doc can I
come back on that very happily for
everyone else comes in because whilst
I'm sure that they're very valid
examples of course if you take the
actual sim competition and you look at
the same things that have happened men
have been penalized more in VO using
that conversation yeah and we bring in
some other fun yeah but I don't need to
be strict you know this is like a game
of tennis let's stick to the rules okay
there's two things going on here is
there sexism and sexism in tennis yeah
there probably is in society there
probably is but where she's holy and
ugly Ron I just want to read you a quote
you're attacking my character
Sedna's Williams you will never ever be
on another court of mine you are the
like right mrs. Williams get over
yourself you don't own the entire tennis
industry I think you have to remember
she's talked about in interviews she has
post
part of issues after the birth and the
line that I am a mother I think actually
a woman's got troubles I think if she
had her time over she wouldn't behave
like that
I think the umpire reacted exactly
correctly and that my great shame before
IU is that the young woman who won
Naomi Osaka who was 20 unfortunately
incredible victory of 20 year old
beating a powerhouse that was somewhat
shaded over and I think that was a great
shame the Roman Tennis Association the
chief executive Steve Simon it's worth
looking what he said the WTA believes
that there should be no difference in
the standards of tolerance provided to
the emotions expressed by men versus
women obvious and it's committed to
working with the sport to ensure that
all players are treated the same gain
obvious then he says we do not believe
that this was done so he's come out yeah
on her sire I didn't see that how much I
only saw us are vanishingly clips on the
news I found her language quite
offensive in any in any sport
she's people should be able to get away
with that sort of language if I get up
now and start smashing with set and
smash a camera and saying I am a father
doesn't justify my actions no I think
this really has divided the game and
it's divided the authorities it's the
Women's Tennis Association and also
Billie Jean King who are about to hear
from have come out and basically said
that when a woman is emotional she's
hysterical and she's penalized for it
when a man does the same he's outspoken
and there are no repercussions Thank You
Serena Williams for calling out this
double standard more voices are needed
to do the same
I mean McEnroe built his career on angry
outbursts why can't a black woman like
Williams who has been a pioneer in the
sport in women's tennis yes if there's a
complaint here I think people got to
focus on on the right complain there may
be an issue to do with where the
coaching should be allowed I mean you
can have coaching and football track and
field basketball and so on
if Serena is hacked off about that then
she should be hacked off about that
what slightly offends me here is she's
parking herself in a column where she
does not be long and
dissing real struggles I mean the truth
is $70,000 fine
I mean honestly she can afford it number
one number two the if you if you're
gonna mount a protest and you know
you're gonna break the rules
what is heroic about breaking the rules
is you know you're gonna take the
punishment Rosa Parks didn't complain
that she got arrested cuz she knew she
was gonna get arrested that was a point
Muhammad Ali
when he refused a draft new he's gonna
be locked up and that's why he did it
to kind of mount the protests and say oh
my gosh you should you know why are you
why are you punishing me that's less
than heroic and I are I find I feel a
bit queasy she's putting herself in she
says she was playing a card she says she
says I'm here fighting for women's right
and for women's equality and for all
kinds of stuff I mean give me a break
I mean honestly some weak yes but but
what we don't know is whether this
there's something going on in tennis
underneath all this and this is just
it's brought to the public attention
that actually women feel that they are
underprivileged in either at all that in
tennis as in almost every other walk of
life women are disadvantaged but then
focus on that fact dignity dignity not
verbal abuse obviously actually not
verbal abuse she might have come out
afterwards and said she did actually
know what she might have come out
afterwards and said look I'm not gonna
argue with the umpire cuz that's it is
caught but we have a big problem here
about the issue of what constitutes
coaching and how you doing that's what a
grown-up would do about coaching at all
I think well that's what the whole she
complained yes she wasn't being coached
but coach then said he had coached no he
said right he didn't say coached her
because then he did he said go up to net
with her you made a gesture because
those go up to net and then she did well
she fen says she didn't see him making
that dead body just clarify we'd not
sure whether she saw that coaching
suicide
Danu and you don't think this is about
whether she saw the coaching or not I
think this is about a slow burn and the
she was like a pressure cooker and she
expressed all the pent-up frustration as
good as she was to lose into a 20 I
think that you're not inside her head
you don't need what you can criticize
her for is her actions and my point is
that this as far as she knew had nothing
to do with whether she was a woman on
Michelle's made the poem that actually
if you look at the data actually there
isn't a bias against off if she had a
point to make by the way the game is
that she being implied she should have
made that point in a dignified way and
of course she's the best tennis player
in the world possibly in history people
are gonna listen to her
you